[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro de Parlement
hebbdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de la semaine au Parlement
et pour commenter cette actualité à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat nous
accueillons cette semaine Jean-René
casenu bonjour vous êtes député
renaissance du Gers et rapporteur
général du budget et à la une cette
semaine le projet de loi immigration
adopté dans son ensemble par le Sénat la
majorité de droite et du centre a durci
le texte avant son examen à l'Assemblée
nationale à voir maintenant si le
ministre de l'Intérieur géralde daranin
va trouver une majorité de députés pour
voter ce projet de loi et on parlera du
marathon budgétaire qui se poursuit au
Sénat le débat a été écourté à
l'Assemblée nationale en séance sur ce
budget 2024 rapidement frappé du 493 le
Parlement doit voter la loi de finance
avant la fin de
l'année et puis la commission d'enquête
sur les groupuscules violents a rendu
son rapport après 6 mois de
les députés constatent une montée de la
violence lors des manifestations et des
formes d'action de plus en plus
radicales la majorité de droite
sénatoriale a donc adopté le projet de
loi immigration dans une version durcie
le texte va désormais être examiné à
l'Assemblée nationale ce sera en
décembre et pour le moment aucune
majorité claire ne se dessine pour voter
ce texte Fabien Réard pour l'adoption
210 contre 115 le Sénat a donc adopté
fumé blan mardi au Palais du Luxembourg
le Sénat adopte le projet de loi
immigration dans une version
considérablement durcie par la majorité
sénatoriale droite et centre se sont
entendus pour supprimer l'aide médicale
d'État instaurer des quôtas
d'immigration économique ou encore
interdire pendant 5 ans l'accès aux
allocations familiales aux nouveaux
arrivants sur notre territoire mais
surtout l'article 3 qui prévoyait la
régularisation automatique de
travailleurs sans papier dans les
secteurs en T
a été supprimé remplacé par une
régularisation au cas par cas après
validation des préfets jamais de mémoire
de députés ou de sénateur LR nous
avavions été la droite aussi ferme on a
durci un texte et j'attends de nos amis
députés bien sûr qu'il le soutiennent et
s'il est détricoté surtout qu'il s'y
oppose avec la dernière énergie à droite
la consigne est claire défendre les
apports du Sénat lors de l'examen du
texte à l'Assemblée nationale équation
difficile voire insoluble pour le
gouvernement pousser LR à voter le texte
mais sans braquer l'aile gauche de la
macronie qui elle tient dur comme faire
au rétablissement du fameux article 3 ce
qui est sûr c'est que ça va être
compliqué puisqueune partie du groupe
auquel j'appartiens souhaite un
rétablissement du texte dans sa version
initiale il a évidemment le trait
symbolique article 3 qui a été
complètement vidé de sa substance euh
donc voilà il y a il me semble qu'il en
tout cas il y a beaucoup de sujets sur
lesquels je suis en profond désaccord
avec les sénateurs un compromis autour
d'une nouvelle réécriture de l'article 3
à miichemin entre les versions du Sénat
et du gouvernement pourrait servir de
terrain d'entente l'enjeu pour
l'exécutif est d'éviter un passage en
force et un recours au 493 Jean casen
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y aura une
majorité de députés pour voter ce projet
de loi immigration et qu'un accord est
possible entre majorité présidentielle
et députés les
républicains alors on va pas mettre la
charue avant les bœ donc il faut que
maintenant le Sénat a fait son travail
et c'est très bien un certain nombre de
sénateurs l'air des Sénat avait dit non
non on veut pas de texte sur
lesimmigration on a quand même un texte
déjà sur lequel donc le Sénat a fait son
travail maintenant c'est à l'Assemblée
nationale de faire de faire son travail
c'est le principe du
bicamérisme et moi je suis persuadé
qu'on arrivera à un compromis et qu'on
arrivera à un texte qui trouvera sa
majorité en tous les cas je le souhaite
il faut le il faut le faire dans cette
dans cet esprit là vous savez on est
encore dans la phase des postures
politiques
qui précède des
négociations montre les muscles on dit
que c'est pas assez dur on veut le
durcir bon posture politique y compris
au sein de la majorité présidentielle à
l gauche oui jaacun ici ESS de pousser
pousser ses idées vous parler LR mais
les il y a ceux qui disent le texte du
Sénat est formidable voilà Monsieur
rillot ceux qui disent quand é il faut
le durcir et ceux qui disent comme
monsieur pradiier qui non non je vterai
compte de toute façon alors il y a un
article qui est au cœur de ce projet de
loi c'est l'article 3 celui qui prévoit
la régularisation des sanspiers dans les
métiers dit en tension est-ce que vous
pensez que l'Assemblée nationale va
rétablir cet article 3 dans sa forme
initiale qui n'est pas du tout celle
votée par les sénateurs et sous la
pression de cette aile gauche macronis
dont vous parlez oui alors il y a dans
les modifications qui ont été faites par
le Sénat chose qui nous paraissent
intéressant hein sur les visas étudiants
par exemple les regroupements familiaux
il y a des choses intéressantes qui sont
proposer je pense qu' on pourra les
prendre des choses qui sont des lignes
rouges pour nous suppression de la me
FR et là sur les 100 papier précisément
oui il y a des sujets sur lesquels on
peut trouver un compromis et et un des
points forts de ce ce texte c'est
effectivement reconnaître que il y a des
métiers en tension aujourd'hui des
entreprises qui ont du mal à recruter ce
soit la restauration ce soit le bâtiment
et on a besoin de C travaill vous
souhaitez cette mesure pour régulariser
les S papierers voz on parle de 7000
personnes par Anin on n'est pas là dans
une vague migratoire épouvantable et
donc entre la posture qui serait celle
du Sénat c'estd simplement
discrétionnaire de la part du préfet et
un droit opposable tel qu'il est dans le
texte moi je suis persuadé qu'on peut
trouver là une combinaison des deux qui
permettent d'arriver à un accord donc un
compromis en train de se se dessiner sur
cet article 3 compromis est en train de
se dessiner surit par exemple comme je
vous l'ai dit donc il faut à la fois il
faut pas que ce soit complètement
discrétionnaire à la main du ça n'a pas
ça n'a pas de de sens donc il faut
peut-être que ce droit opposable
aujourd'hui les sénateurs veulent pas
que l'entreprise demande soit quand les
sénateurs souhaitent que l'entreprise
demande également enfin l'accord de
l'entreprise soit nécessaire nous ça
nous paraît pas obligatoire voilà il il
y a des compromis maintenant il faut
travailler sur le sur ce texte alors les
sénateurs LR ont transformé l'aide
médicale d'État en une aide plutôt
d'urgence et en restreignant le panier
de soins pour les étrangers en situation
irrégulière est-ce que l'assemblée va
revenir sur ce vote du du Sénat oui je
le souhaite en tous les cas on va
voir je suis rapporteur général du
budget et peut-être que le par que ça
coûte cher justement laame ça coûte cher
c'est un milliard un milliard un
milliard 2 bon c'est le milliard le plus
ausculté de de la dépense publique
française si nous faisions ce travail
d'observation
d'optimisation de l'ensemble de nos
dépenses notre déficit serait bien moins
important qu'il n'est aujourd'hui je
dire que ça tout le monde regarde depuis
très longtemps il y a eu x rapport
pourquoi on a besoin de ça parce que les
médecins vous le disent d'abord c'est
extrêmement difficile quand quelqu'un
vient dans votre cabinet renvoie sur le
S d'Hippocrate vous pouvez pas comme ça
renvoyer les gens ça pratiquement c'est
pas possible c'est pas ce que veulent
faire ensuite il y a un risque un sujet
de santé publique c'estàd si vous ne
soignez pas ces gens-là sur notre sur
notre territoire vous avez un risque de
d'épidémies de de de de nouvelles
maladies qui ne sont plus chez nous donc
donc il faut absolument euh maintenir
cette tte picale en parallèle il y a un
rapport hein qui a été demandé
euh monsieur Evin et Monsieur stéphanini
stéphanini absolument qui va être rendu
dans quelques jours on peut toujours
optimiser mais mais c'est du domaine
pour éviter notamment le tourisme
médical parce que oui mais ça n'existe
pas nexiste pas oui ça n'existe pas
c'est un fantasme ça ça n'existe pas
donc maintenant qu'on puisse optimiser
encore cette dépense regardez euh bon ça
évidemment il faut le faire mais c'est
du décret là c'est on sent bien que
c'est une posture politique vous l'avez
dit tourisme médical et vous pensez que
les députés les républicains dans la
négociation avec la majorité
présidentielle pourrai abandonner ce
symbole politique ils Arbor cette
restriction de l'aide médicale d'État
bah on va voir comment ça se je je peux
pas répondre à la place des LR surtout
que comme leur nom l'indique ils sont
très nombreux et ils ont des postures
aujourd'hui et des avis très différents
sur le sujet mais ça n'est pas dans le
texte initial donc un des risques pour
l'air c'est que ce soit cavalier tout
simplement que so dispositif soit
cavalier oui mais M attend moi je on a
aucun problème en discuter je crois que
c'est important d'être factuel sur son
intérêt ce qu'il apporte et et pourquoi
il faut main C aide est nécessaire selon
vous pour moi cette aide est nécessaire
c'est absolument d'un point de vue santé
publique d' protection des Français vous
parlez de posture politique vous dites
qu'à un moment donné vous espérez qu'un
compromis soit trouvé que les uns et les
autres arrivent à discuter si ce n'est
pas le cas faute de majorité est-ce que
le 493 vous semblera inévitable pour
faire passer cette loi immigration et je
ne le souhaite pas
moi je vois je suis vraiment farouement
opposé au 493 sur ce texte qu'on utilise
le 493 parce que nous avons besoin d'un
budget on en parlera tout à l'heure
c'est une chose maintenant sur ces
textte il faut qu'on trouve des
majorités moi je vous dire euh il
faudrait que les LR retourne à leur
circonscription et explique pourquoi ils
sont contre un texte qui durcit la
position sur tous ceux qui n'ont pas
leur place dans notre pays parce que ce
texte là il fait ça aussi il fait il il
facilite les procédures sur les octtf ou
sur les expulsions donc il va vooir qu'
expque de quitter le
territoire absolument donc il falloir
qu'ils expliquent à leurs électeurs que
là où on veut accélérer ces dispositifs
ils sont contre et de la même manière
ceux qui sont à gauche il va falloir
qu'ils explique que sous un certain
nombre de métiers sous tension on fait
on veut faire une régulation des des
titres de séjour avec un titre de séjour
spécifique sous condition là aussi très
limité il va falloir qu'ils expliquent
pourquoi ils sont contre alors on le
rappelle sauf les textes budgétaires le
gouvernement a le droit d'utiliser un
seul 493 par session parlementaire si on
vous écoute selon vous ce texte
immigration ce n'est pas le bon texte
pour griller ce 493 si la majorité n'est
pas certaine non mais vous avez donné
une des explications d'abord je pense
que
euh notre majorité et et la première
ministre est très claire jeis saluer son
son engagement depuis sa nomination
c'est de trouver systématiquement des
majorités surt les textes et il est
arrivé a pratiquement tout le temps une
cinquantaine de textes maintenant à
l'exception des textes budgétaires et
encore certains textes budgétaires on a
trouvé des compromis et euh à
l'exception évidemment de de la réforme
des des retraites mais sur les autres on
cherche des compromis il faut absolument
euh qu'on trouve ces ces ces compromis
mais alors juste je je répète ma
question faute de compromis s'il n'y a
pas de majorité sur ce texte immigration
est-ce qu'il faut entre parenthèses
entre guillemets griller ce 493 ou alors
laisser
l'échec ce projet se faire le coup
politique est trop important c'est pour
ça que je vous dis euh euh après on
serait euh si vous voulez sans
possibilité d' 493 pendant les 6
prochains mois ce qui quand même nous
mettrait en grande difficulté dans les
négociations vis-à-vis des autres partis
politiques donc c'est une raison
supplémentaire c'est pas la première
raison pourquoi pour laquelle il faut
pas faire de 493 en tous les cas c'est
c'est une c'est une raison
supplémentaire alors on va suivre ce
projet de loi immigration les prochains
jours mais en attendant on va vous
parler du budget puisque vous êtes
rapporteur général du budget jean-renis
casenu les sénateurs ont commencé à
examiner ce PLF 2024 comme on l'appelle
à l'Assemblée le débat a tourné court
puisque le gouvernement a rapidement
utilisé l'article 493 pour passer le
budget sans vote faute de majorité Elsa
mondingava du budget 2024 on retiendra
l'utilisation très rapide du 493 avant
même l'examen des article de la partie
recette aujourd'hui le constat est clair
aucun groupe d'opposition n'est prêt à
voter ce projet de loi de finances or
notre pays a besoin de ce budget aussi
sur le fondement de l'article le 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution j'engage la
responsabilité de mon gouvernement le
gouvernement innove même en matière de
493 parce que je crois pas qu'on ait
déclenché un 493 un jour sur un budget
avant même qu'on ait commencé l'examen
des article sur le fond maintenant dans
ce budget le déficit sera ramené à 4,4 %
du PIB en 2024 avec toujours l'objectif
de passer sous les 3 % en 2027 16
milliards d'euros d'économie seront
réalisé en grande partie avec la fin du
bouclier énergétique un gage de sérieux
et de responsabilité pour le ministre de
l'Économie les oppositions imaginent un
monde où tout est gratuit le malheur et
la réalité c'est que tout coûte quelque
chose que tout a un coût et que l'air de
l'argent gratuit est définitivement fini
et qu'il serait t que les oppositions
s'en rendent enfin compte des
amendements dépensiers il en a plus
comme à Gravelotte pour autant la droite
accuse le gouvernement de laisser filer
les déficits quand la gauche regrette la
fin de mesures protectrice tous les
signaux budgétaires ont atteint un seuil
d'alerte inédit notre dette dépasse
désormais les 3000 milliards d'euros
c'est près de 45000 € de dett par
français le budget proposé ne suivra pas
la hausse de l'inflation la fin du
bouclier énergétique aggravera encore la
situation de bcoup alors que l'inflation
persiste encore dans l'énergie après une
adoption par 493 à l'Assemblée nationale
le budget sera discuté en séance
publique au Sénat à partir du jeudi 23
novembre alors jeanren cas9 on le
rappelle vous êtes rapporteur général du
budget alors pourtant le débat a eu lieu
en en commission mais pas en séance
publique en tout cas il y a eu une
discussion générale et après pas même un
seul article n'a été examiné ce que vous
regrettez qu'il nit pas quand même eu un
début de discussion que le gouvernement
a fait le choix de tout de suite mettre
le 493 alors peut-être une précision si
vous permettez c'est que que le débat a
eu lieu en commission commission des
finances longue journée de débat avec de
très très très nombreux amendements il a
eu lieu sur la deuxème partie du budget
on a passé pratiquement une semaine dans
l'hémicycle à discuter desmissions
agriculture desmission éducation
démissions outremaire donc on a aussi
passé une semaine mais c'est vrai que
sur la partie 1 la première ministre
engagé sa responsabilité tout de suite
pourquoi parce que et je respecte moi là
pour le coup la position des oppositions
c'est que il y est de tradition dans
notre pays que ce soit dans les
exécutifs régionaux départementaux dans
les grandes municipalités quand vous
êtes dans l'opposition vous ne votez pas
le budget qui est l'acte si vous voulez
par excellence politique le marqueur
politique c'est le marqueur politique
donc vous ne les votez pas et donc
toutes les oppositions nous ont dit
assez logiquement qu'elle ne le
voteraiit pas donc une fois qu'elle le
vote pas si vous voulez autant écouter
les débats a TR une passe not temp à
nous dire nous reprocher on a des débats
mais ça sert à rien de toute façon vous
retiendrez ce que vous voudrez de nos
débats donc ça nos débats ne ser servent
à rien bon deuxième point aussi c'est
que il y a ça je le regrette il y a deux
dérives dans notre débat politique
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée nationale que
ne connaissent pas les sénateurs en tous
les cas pas pour l'instant c'est la
multiplication du nombre d'amendements
on a multiplié par 7 le nombre
d'amendements un exemple un chiffre pour
ce budget pour ce budget pour la partie
1 et 2 en homisyquele on est à 11000
amendements 11000 amendements donc ontié
par 7 en 7 ans le nombre d'amendements
et ensuite il y a une sorte de
déresponsabilisation d'un certain nombre
de partis politiqu que je ne nommerai
pas sur les montants il y a des
amendements à 12 milliards il y a des
missions sur lesquelles les amendements
sont tellement importants qu'ils vident
complètement les crédits qu quand vous
regardez je donner un der un dernier
chiffre les les les amendements de des
oppositions de la France insoumise pour
le prendre que la France insoumise sont
au-delà du budget il y a entre 400 et
500 milliards d'amendements de la France
insoumise mais vous pensez pas qu'il
aurait pu avoir des amendements de
l'opposition plus raisonnable selon vous
qui aurait pu être débattu discuté en
séance et peut-être retenu à la fin par
le gouvernement après 493 mais c'est ce
qu'on a fait c'està-dire que l'un
n'empêche pas l'autre séance oui
absolument mais l'un n'empêche pas
l'autre et je ça et ça pose de vraies
questions hein c'est-à-dire que
effectivement c'est le gouvernement avec
son Tombre du ministère avec le
rapporteur général qui décide infiner
les amendements qui sont retenus parmi
les 11000 dont je vous parle qui sont
déposés et il en a retenu un nombre
important de la part des oppositions
mais c'est vrai qu'on est plus dans le
cadre de ce de ce débat je le regrette
c'est un peu le le coup à la fois de
cette majorité relative c'est une
conséquence du fait que nous sommes une
majorité relative et aussi le fait que
ce nombre d'amendements et ces montants
est en train d'emboliser notre notre
assemblée mais il y avait quand même une
mesure qui a été votée justement en
commission des finances et assez
largement par les députés la taxe sur
les super dividendes c'est une demande
c'était une demande du du du MoDem
depuis longtemps elle a été votée et le
gouvernement de l'a par tenu est-ce que
vous pensez pas qu'il aurait pu faire ce
geste cette mesure de
justice fiscale vous vous considérez que
c'est une mesure de justice fiscale moi
je considère que c'est une hausse
d'impôt qu'elle donne un signal très
mauvais vis-à-vis des investisseurs dans
notre pays ce que fait ce queessaie de
faire notre majorité depuis 6 ans c'est
rendre notre pays attractif on recrée
des emplois industriels pour la première
fois depuis des dizaines d'années dans
notre pays
les investissements augmentent les
investissements on est devenu le pays où
les investissements étrangers sont le
plus important en Europe et ça ça crée
des emplois ça crée de la valeur on a
créé 2 millions d'emplois depuis 2017
tout ça c'est basé sur le fait que au
contraire nous baissons les impôts pour
les entreprises et nous baissons
d'ailleurs les impôts pour les
particuliers depuis depuis depuis depuis
6 ans doncy il il y a une vraie logique
c'est la politique de la de l'offre et
donc on est on est très attaché à ça à
l'attrac activité de notre pays pour
créer de la valeur dans notre pays ça
marche attention sign au contraire mais
au final quand on regarde ce budget 2024
pas de hausse d'impôt sur ces super
dividendes et de l'autre côté c'est la
fin du bouclier tarifaire qui protégeait
les Français en période d'inflation
notamment du prix de l'énergie et c'est
normal est-ce que vous pensez pas qu'il
y a une partie des Français qui qui se
dit bah voilà c'est de l'injustice
sociale ce qui a été voté on nous on
nousompag on nous accompagne plus face à
l'inflation hier alors ça ça n'est pas
tout à fait vrai non plus euh il y a le
bouclier énergétique sur l'électricité
continue en 2024 donc il y aura un
bouclier qui protège les Français
aujourd'hui il paye l'électricité à peu
près un tiers moins cher que ce qu'il
pit s'il y avait pas ce bouclier et
l'année prochaine ce sera aussi le cas
donc il y a encore un bouclier pour
protéger les Français il y a une mesure
sur le carburant pour aider no
compatriotes qui sera voté au 100 € par
an c'est oui oui oui c'est beaucoup
moins que l'année d'avant non non non
c'est pas beaucoup moins que l'année
d'avant c'était 100 € l'année dernière
également des remis sur le prix de
l'essence oui mais l'essence était pas
aujourd'hui l'essence est quand même
moins élevé qu'il a été on est plus sur
le pic qu'on a connu donc il y a encore
des mesures de soutien on a augmenter
moi je veux bien qu'on regarde ce qui va
pas mais c'est un budget où on augmente
de 3,9 milliards d'euros par exemple le
budget de l'Éducation nationale pourquoi
parce qu'on augmente les salaires des
des des enseignants et c'est normal il
était temps de de le faire pourquoi
aussi notre budget est important c'est
que on augmente tous les minimas sociaux
donc les retraites toutes ces dépenses
sociales et tout ces toutes ces
retraites sont excès sur l'inflation
donc si vous voulez
normalement normalement il y a pas de
perte de pouvoir d'achat puisque les
retraite augmente de la même manière que
que l'inflation alors je voudrais vous
parler d'une chose la dette la dette
française qui atteint des niveaux record
supérieurs à 3000 milliards d'euros à
l'heure où l'on se parle elle continue
d'augmenter de façon dangereuse
finalement au point que certains
certains organismes internationaux comme
le FMI mettent en garde la France en
prévoyant un plan de rigueur à venir
prochainement est-ce que vous prenez la
menace au sérieux écoutez oui je prends
la menace au au sérieux ét endetté à ce
point c'est jamais bon c'est jamais bon
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous
disais tout à l'heure que les
oppositions y compris celle qui nous
accusent de trop dépenser qu de fait
quand vous regardez leurs amendements
c'est les amendements de dépenses
supplémentaires et donc moi en tant que
rapporteur général je je j'alerte et et
d'ailleurs moi j'ai fait des
propositions pour des des baisses de
dépenses dans le dans le budget j'ai pas
amener des dépenses supplémentaires j'ai
proposé des baisses de dépenses dans
notre budget selon vous quelles
économies la France doit faire dans
cette situation c'est un travail un
petit peu compliqué mais peut-être
peut-être répondre oui la dette coûte
beaucoup d'argent aujourd'hui ceux qui
nous ont expliqué que c ça servait à
rien de la rembourser que c'était pas
important que c'était pas grave de
l'avoir de la dette on le voit
aujourd'hui potentiellement c'est 74
milliards simplement d'intérêt de la
dette en 2027 donc oui et c'est pour ça
que notre budget 2024 c'est un budget
responsable nous baissons le le le
déficit de 4 9 % à 4,4 donc c'est un un
un effort très important de maîtrise de
nos dépenses publiques et l'objectif
c'est 2,7 % de déficit en 2027 donc
c'est très important parce qu'autrement
on le paye on le paye avec les intérêts
et et si pour une raison ou une autre
notre note était dégradé ou si les taux
d'intérêt devaient augmenter c'est tous
les Français qui ont Péré la note vos
taux d'intérêt pour l'immobilier
augmenteraiit les taux d'intérêt pour
les entreprises augmenterai donc tout le
monde serait pénalisé donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut absolument
voir cette maîtrise des comptes publics
Jean gaz on va passer à notre dernier
thème un cap supplémentaire a été
franchi dans la violence et la
conclusion majeureur de la commission
d'enquête qui a travaillé sur les
groupuscules violents et qui a rendu son
rapport les députés ont voulu faire la
lumière sur ces violents survenu pendant
les manifestations notamment pendant
celle de contre la réforme des retraites
ou encore à sain-sine écoutez ce que
nous dit à notre micro le président de
cette commission il y a une sorte de
d'élargissement de de de la violence
elle elle se diffuse de de plus en plus
et surtout ce que montre bien nos
travaux c'est que elle est de plus en
plus légitimé y compris dans les dans
les discours politiques et le fait par
exemple de ne pas dénoncer cette cette
violence est en soi déjà déjà un
problème cette banalisation là elle
inquiète parce que des responsables de
manifestants de manifestation devrait
avoir conscience que quand on organise
une manifestation on doit tout mettre en
pour que celle-ci puisse se dérouler
dans le dans le calme jean-renac cas les
recommandations de cette commission
d'enquête doivent figurer dans une
future loi qui serait transpartisan
dit-on ce ne serait pas la première loi
antiasseur est-ce que une loi peut
vraiment
endiguer la montée de de phénomènes tels
que le décrivent le président et le
rapporteur de cette commission d'enquête
est-ce que le législateur est puissant
dans ce domaine c'est nécessaire et pas
suffisant si je puis ainsi m'exprimer
donc moi c'est ce qu'on disait de toutes
les lois qui ont été détail de de ce
rapport qui sera publié dans les
prochains jours mais cette cette montée
des violences c'est plus de 1500
gendarmes et policiers qui ont été
blessés cette année dans les différents
types de manifestation c'est absolument
insupportable et les Français le
condamnent le condamnent vraiment dans
leur grande très grande majorité à à
part quelques-uns donc c'est absolument
insupportable donc il faut
effectivement tenir compte de ces de ces
recommandations pour voir comment on
peut à la fois mieux encadrer
ces manifestants me les condamner faut
pas il y a pas d'autres mot soit à titre
individuel soit les associations qui
elles-mêm pousse à ce genre de de
comportement moi je suis vraiment très
sévère par rapport à ça quand je vois
président d' colég ver qui dit qu'il
faut transformer l'Assemblée nationale
en Zade enfin vous voyez que c'est c'est
c'est c'est gravissime donc ça n'est pas
simplement une loi c'est aussi une prise
de conscience démocratique collective
que les policiers et les gendarmes sont
là pour nous protéger et justement
est-ce que certains partis certaines
organisations politiques ont une
responsabilité indirecte dans cette
montée de la violence dans la société
ils ont une montée ils ont une
responsabilité absolument évidente par
leurs propos si voulez et on voit bien
que c'est ce qui cherche il cherche le
le chaos le droit de manifester est
absolument essentiel dans notre pays
mais il faut on peut le faire il y a des
règles on peut le faire une formidable
manifestation contre l'antisémitisme il
y a une une semaine elle s'est faite
dans le calme donc on peut manifester
dans le calme il y a des partis
politiques la France insoumise en
particulier qui aujourd'hui poussent au
crime c'est pas d'autres mot alors la
dissolution du mouvement les
soulèvements de la Terre a été annulé la
semaine dernière par le Conseil d'État
car elle a été jugée disproportionné
décision prise par le le ministère de
l'Intérieur le gouvernement est-il sorti
de l'État de droit en voulant dissoudre
les soulèvements de la terre écoutez on
a tenté notre chance il a tenté sa
chance et donc on est dans un état de
droit puisque justement ça a été retoqué
donc c'est bien la preuve qu'on est dans
un état de droit et on respectera
évidemment cette cette décision
maintenant il faut continuer à
travailler peut-être modifier la loi
pour je le je le dis être extrêmement
sévère avec ces associations qui et ces
individus qui sont dans la violence et
et qui veulent déstabiliser qui veulent
diviser notre pays leur objectif c'est
de diviser notre pays certains partis
politiques vous dites euh alimentent
cette ces mouvements on voit bien dans
leur dans leurs propos voyz quand vous
dites quand le responsable parti
politique dit la police tue qu'est-ce
qu'il fait d'autre que d'alimenter cette
violence et d'alimenter ces conflits au
sein de notre de notre société donc moi
je voudrais encore profiter de cette
occasion
pour exprimer mon ma solidarité
vis-à-vis des forces de l'ordre qui font
un travail formidable deain général en
France et ben ce sera le mot de la fin
merci Jean des cas d'avoir été l'invité
de Parlement Hebdo et merci d'avoir
suivi cette émission et à la semaine
prochaine pour suivre l' temps fort de
la semaine au
[Musique]
Parlement